[Music]
the Titans and Godzilla king of the
monsters were in mindless beasts roaming
and destroying everything in sight they
obeyed direct commands from an alpha
predator or an alpha Titan most of the
Titans were in deep slumber hibernating
their way to glory and when the military
hit Godzilla with an oxygen destroyer
weapon the entire situation turn out for
worse Ghidorah wasn't affected by the
weapon it being an alien guy Judah came
from the stars was invulnerable to most
weapons including the oxygen destroyer
anyway it came out as new alpha and his
alpha bioacoustics was the only one left
to sound out to the entire world and all
the Titans woke up Titanus mizura was
the only child in other than godzilla
that was unaffected by it but why was
Matra able to resist a call here are
some reasons why number 5 her
metamorphosis made her into a true alpha
species Matra was still at a larval
stage in the early stages of the movie
she was awakened and somehow did respond
to an alpha signal that was a
combination of Godzilla and human
acoustics that being imprinted on her
she went onto the cocoon States and when
she reimbursed the call had already been
sung and since she was he was developing
into the final form she was able to shut
off any outside interference her final
form was also an alpha super species
form that could fight off most other
Titans number 4 symbiotic relationship
with Godzilla it was mentioned that
Marshall was in some sort of symbiotic
relationship with the big G the exact
nature of the interspecies relationship
is unknown but we can deduce that since
it is a protected Titan and Godzilla was
also a protected Thailand they often in
the past had to team up to defeat
destroy Titans like many others
mutualism symbiotic relationships mater
and Godzilla had some sort of semi
obligatory dependence on one another
another reason why she came in search
for him and resisted the alphas signal
number 3 she already had an egg and has
to protect it
it was teased in the credits and post
credits scenes that an egg have been
discovered and if you're wondering what
it is we can tell you that Matra in the
past has been able to transfer her
essence into an egg to make sure that
she lives on to the next generation
Matra is immortal and because of that it
gave her the mantra for eco balls the
challenge for Lauren and Ghidorah
mom how Mattoon never been defeated in
battle the queen of the monsters in this
movie was never actually defeated in
battle before the alpha battle in Boston
Ronan was also not defeated prior to him
being awakened in Ireland omona
therefore he challenged and briefly
fought Ghidorah but since he lost a
fight he bowed down rodent somehow
reminded me of Starscream I wonder why
so when Matra came into the fray she was
fresh out of her cocoon and had all the
energy to fend off the bioacoustics of
Ghidorah and even help his partner
godzilla in the fight for life she might
have fended off Ghidorah alongside
godzilla in the past trapping the
monster zero in the Antarctic ice number
one she is a life-giver and Ghidorah is
a destroyer but the main reason why
Matra was able to shut off the alpha
signal was that she was a Titan that was
meant to restore order and protect life
on Earth Titanus missourah is a super
species that evolved on earth millions
of years ago many of the titles were
also earth species Ghidorah came from
space he fell from the stars and was
still that in the movies do you like to
destroy a living extinction event it
would have conflicted what motorist
brainwaves imagine a protected Titan
fully form that is immortal and with a
symbiotic relationship with another
alpha protected species and here comes
an invader from space with a destroyed
signal combine all these factors it
would have given more to the ability to
resist the alpha call when this brings
us to the end of the video do like share
and subscribe for more related videos
and click on the notification bell for
regular and actual notifications
[Music]